well I I suppose the thing that has been
obsessing me for quite a few years is
where does creativity come from where
does intelligence come from
and I'm more and more convinced it comes
out of communities rather than as we
tend to think out of individuals it
comes out of the whole sort of Quagmire
holy Ecology of thinking and doing
um some of it looks like intellectual
work some of it doesn't but it's what
produces new ideas so so I often say now
that um
new ideas are usually articulated by one
person but they're nearly always
generated by a lot of people
and we tend to reward that one person
at the expense of the of the other
people I've been a beneficiary of that
reward system but I'm more and more
suspicious of it
and do you think
the interaction of the individual with
groups of people
is the crucial part there I'm thinking
about the band of the way a rock band
works the world that you work in
what is that interaction
well it's very interesting I often use
the word chemistry which is the word
everybody
uses but but I mean it in a very literal
sense if you take iron
100 iron you have iron there's something
that's brittle heavy and so on if you
add four percent of carbon to it you get
something called Steel
and that's a quite different material
and very often the chemistry of bands is
like that that there's one person who
makes a lot of noise and seems to be the
leader
and there's very often one other person
who doesn't make very much noise but
actually is equally indispensable and I
find that's true in all sorts of social
situations as well one one of the things
that came to interest me was those
creative situations called salons
which very much were part of the late
19th century in the early 20th century
salons were nearly always large groups
of people many of whom don't remain in
the history books but actually were part
of the ecology including particularly
the hostesses who usually were putting
these salons on and bringing people
together Mrs Dalloway yes yeah
Janice come on the individual and ideas
and creativity and solutions
listening to uh Brian by the way when we
are on our own we usually have the same
kind of conversation so either we're
very interesting or we were exceedingly
boring I've never mind
we do this is the kind of thing we're
talking about you know yeah why do
people make art this is something that
you know with we've spent hours talking
about regarding the individual
allow me to um
come to the subject from my own trauma
of being an economist
because anybody who has had the tough
lack of having studied economics even
very little you recall that the first
page of
or you know introductory textbook
defines the rational person homo
economicals
it's always a he because only a male
could be so deprived
and depraved so the the individual is
defined in economics as a bundle of
preferences
seeking satisfaction
given constraints and you're rational to
the extent that you maximize your
preference satisfaction given the amount
of money you have what other people who
appear in the scene of economic theory
as an obstacle
it's a community instead of being
empowering is you know is what for
example starter used to say other people
are hell
but he meant it in an existential way
the economists actually mean it
literally
now this is of course effectively what
you have is a Robinson Cruiser
approach to the economy if you look at
look at the bank of England's
econometric models that the bank of
England uses in order to predict
inflation unemployment brexit as if they
can ever predict what will happen with
brexit given that there is a sample of
zero to work with but anyway so
all these models are predicated upon the
assumption that the economy
is founded on rumberson Cruiser and his
clones
they have no relationship except that
through the market mechanism so buying
and selling
no one influences anyone
there's no money and there's no debt
because you cannot have money without
the community
it's like language remember what
wickenstein used to say there can be no
such thing as a private language
something we create together you know if
you're a single person on the planet and
you've grown up on your own there's no
way you can have a language
unless somebody taught it to you so
this
is rather sad
depiction of the individual which by the
way is a Savage
is at the heart of the way in which
mainstream economics thinks about the
world
and one may ask you the question so why
is this the case are they uh not
philosophically
sophisticated enough no the answer is
there's a lot of money in it because the
whole point about mainstream economics
is to justify capitalism and capitalism
justifies itself on the basis of the
fiction that wealth is something that is
produced individually
and then the state comes and taxes it
when it's exactly opposite wealth is
produced socially collectively and then
it's privatized
so um
this juxtaposition Jackson position
between the individual and the
collective this is if
the dominant ideology which supports
profit making and a particular kind of
class structure it's it's a sermons it's
the religion it's the theory it's it
plays exactly the same role that the
Middle Ages the bishop in legitimizing
the power of the emperor of the lord of
the baron of the king
and what we need to do in me we need to
dissolve it and Brian gave me a
fantastic example
not example idea of how this is
dissolved
think about the economists model of
competition right it's it's a bit like a
kind of Olympic sport where my victory
is your loss
but a far more interesting model of what
happens in the world is the band
where you know you've got highly
individualistic people usually on the
screen on the stage
but what's going on is while at the same
time each one of them trying to prove to
the audience and to each other and to
themselves that they are the best of the
launch unless there is the chemistry
unless there is the Synergy each one of
them just creates noise